as a side note allow me to say a few
words about Israel and Palestine
while this conversation with Omar
Suleiman was mostly exploring the
history and beauty of Islam and the
Muslim Community we did delve briefly
into the topic of Israel and Palestine
this topic is an extremely challenging
one and an extremely important one
it is Deep Roots and implications in U.S
politics in global geopolitics in
Military and religious conflicts Wars
and atrocities and basic struggle of all
human beings to survive to protect their
loved ones and to flourish as
individuals and as communities
I did not want to cover this topic in a
solely scholarly fashion much like with
the war in Ukraine it is not simply a
story of History politics religion and
national identity it is also a deeply
human story
to cover this topic in the way that my
gut and my heart says to do it I have to
talk to everyone to leaders and people
on all sides Muslim and Jewish Israeli
and Palestinian from refugees to
soldiers from Scholars to extremists
I'm not sure if that's possible or wise
but like Forrest Gump said I'm not a
smart man and maybe you know how the
rest of that goes
I just like to follow my heart to
whatever place it leads
I ask the Muslim and the Jewish
communities for your patience and
support as they explore this topic I
will make many mistakes and I'll be
listening to all voices so I can learn
and do better
I've become distinctly aware that my
Approach of talking to people from all
walks of life with empathy and
compassion but with backbone can create
enemies on all sides
I don't quite yet understand why this is
but I'm learning to accept it as the
reality of the world
hopefully in the end whatever happens
whatever silly thing I do has a chance
of adding a bit of love to the world
thanks for going along with me on this
journey
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Omar Suleiman